vct playoffs wrapped up worldwide this
past weekend and although there's a lot
of familiar faces coming back from
masters 2 there are some new
representatives that we can be excited
for except finally broke their 4th place
curse loud drx and prx continue to
dominate their respective regions and
nobody in emea managed to stop fnatic
but there were a few upsets over the
weekend and a bit of controversy too so
let's get into it all now
well
except finally did it after a year and a
half of fourth place finishes and nearly
a two hour long tech delay in their
lower bracket match against faze they
finally managed to qualify for their
first international land dicey vs bcj
both of these players have been monsters
in this series
the responsibility the mantle of it has
never been higher taking it the side
angle that he's broken his ankles bcj
with a teleport off to the side except
with that they have secured their
position they will be representing north
america but exit didn't just stop there
they managed to get revenge on optic on
sunday to become the na champions and
secure themselves first seed going into
copenhagen as well as a group stage buy
a lot of people have expressed concern
that maybe a team like exit who have no
international land experience could have
benefited from starting the event in the
group stage but honestly i think they'll
be fine we all know that the guard
didn't exactly have the best showing in
iceland but exxon actually has a lot
more experience than them on land
between aeryn and death they have years
of international experience from their
crossfire and cs go days with this win
exced have also secured their spot at
champions at the end of the year so they
have a lot to be excited for i'm happy
for them this has been a long time
coming and xed absolutely deserved this
i'm pumped to see cryo and zekken on
land 2 because as expected they popped
off in playoffs as for optic they
continue to be the most consistent n a
team they've continued their trend of
finishing in second place domestically
and once fns and crashes recover from
kovid i fully expect them to clean up
some of their game in time for
copenhagen next let's move on to emea
with fnatic they only dropped a single
map on their way to the number one seed
and they even three owed fpx in the
final but it really came down to the
wire how much more can you do zip hands
trying to dodge if the defuse is coming
in you gotta deny it you gotta stop it
close out the map close out the season
and become the vct uba champions right
here
what a close
what a close to this series again like i
said that almost does justice for both
of these teams really and just how close
that was now fnatic finishing first
doesn't really come as a surprise
they've looked dominant all season long
and i can't wait to see this iteration
of the roster on lan they look insane
right now despite angel waking up to the
sound of rockets and kiev fpx qualified
as the second seed out of emir
unfortunately according to a report
today from dexerto fpx might be forced
to play with three stand-ins if xiao
soiguetsu and angel are unable to attend
due to travel restrictions in russia and
ukraine the third and final seed from
emea goes to guild who took down mek
last week and secured their spot at
their first international lan capping
off a solid stage 2. i'm really looking
forward to seeing what guilds can do in
copenhagen they've been a solid team for
a long time and i can see them making a
decent run over in brazil and korea not
a whole lot has changed loud continue to
dominate their region and they qualified
for masters too pretty easily
from
drx continues to prove that korea is
also unfortunately a one-team region
they didn't drop a single map throughout
all of stage two
absolutely insane explosion of death
stacks fighting two rp with a blade
sword picks up two of his own and moves
is the last man standing trying to make
his way out through gardens finds one
but rp will be the finisher a third kill
and it's 13-3 drx are your stage two
champions they are going to copenhagen
with this win though drx have also
secured their spot in champions next i
gotta talk about what i think is the
most hype region right now
japan over the weekend the japanese
region showcased just how passionate
they are with yet another insane lan
event roughly 22 000 fans turned up to
saitama super arena to watch north upton
get revenge on zeta division
now as a zeta division fan i'd be lying
if i said i wasn't disappointed but
north eption 100 deserves this they've
been on the cusp of qualifying for an
international land since last year's lcq
and it's good to see the competition
grow in japan now please just give us an
international land in japan riot these
events that they've been hosting are
wild over in the apac region honestly
not a lot has changed paper rex were
crowned champions and zersha qualified
as the second seed inside the pit the
vital strike mind freak looking great
forsaken with another and ladies and
gentlemen it is going to be paper rex
your victor's here to absolutely
decimate zersha unfortunately thailand
has been completely denied and it is the
absolute giants of the apac region both
teams have also qualified for champions
in september lastly i gotta show some
love to leviathan who finally managed to
dethrone crew over in latina
led by crew's former coach owner
leviathan finally have a shot at
representing their region on the world
stage while crew still has one last shot
at qualifying they play nip on thursday
for the 12th and final spot in
copenhagen the past few weeks have been
insane if you're a fan of pro valorem we
have some new teams coming up some
returning faces and the competition is
closer than ever before i'll refrain
from making any sort of prediction just
yet because as we saw in iceland almost
all of the regions can compete so no
matter who you support i think we can
all agree that copenhagen might just be
the most exciting valerian event yet
i think i've said insane like a couple
times now let's stop saying insane let's
try some yeah let's try some nuts i feel
like i'm sweating
i need to stop sweating
i have water i have water here
all right maybe it was a bad idea to
take a shower and then like immediately
jump in